neo-nazis on trial how big is the terror
network an interview with Sebastian a
dirty chair of the German parliament
inquiry mr. Dottie the long-awaited
trial of the far-right terrorist cells
the National Socialist underground or
NSU is set to begin in Munich next week
you know the only survivor of the three
alleged killers is on trial for the
murder of ten people in Germany nine of
the victims came from immigrant families
it's a trial that's gaining massive
attention what are you expecting from
this trial in bayson V Odin Hamza a
bathroom in undies and puts us off
cowardice entertain the point of these
proceedings is for the courts to decide
if the charges are credible if the
accusations against the five defendants
be out of shape and for alleged
accomplices are true once of course we
politicians will be watching this trial
closely in terms of politically
motivated crimes this is the most
important case since the trial of the
Red Army Faction in the 1970s what says
second side and never on me talk soon
Lindsey offseason puts us in looking at
this trial in Munich now with that in
mind are you just expecting the court to
judge the case at hand
Barr are you expecting more far-reaching
insight into how this unprecedented
series of right-wing murders could take
place in this country Fonda globalists
Erskine I think that the court has a
different task than a parliamentary
investigation committee basically it's
the courts duty to decide whether the
charges brought by federal prosecutors
are true and whether the plaintiffs are
guilty as charged
the court won't be making judgments on
what failings security authorities made
who failed to track down this ultra
right-wing terrorist group for 13 years
that's basically the job of the
parliamentary commission that's tasked
with addressing the NS use crime that's
who Fulton is seems very likely that be
at a cheaper the principal defendant
will be keeping silent throughout the
trial does that mean we should keep our
expectations low do you think the
government ought to be in I don't think
we should expect to learn too much from
the trials it will depend largely on
what the defendants
if they say anything at all they're not
obliged to make self incriminating
statements it'll also depend on how much
insight can be gained from witness
testimony enjoy I think many of the
victims families hope this trial will
clear up all unanswered questions but I
think those questions will have to be
addressed outside the court rooms as
it's not the courts job nobody must know
sidebars cadets are Asaf carbide
advances on here off cupboard escalators
the size and the pulley to show off so
you don't expect to see the court
address the political aspect of this
series of murders which sent shockwaves
across Germany when the case first came
to light in November of 2011 and the
padishah of clearing evidence in East 19
no addressing this case at the political
level will take place elsewhere for one
in the parliamentary investigation
Commission we're looking at how our
police and intelligence authorities
could have failed so greatly that this
group was able to commit these crimes
for 13 years and was only discovered by
coincidence in November 2011 it's not
the duty of the court to figure that out
but the court has to decide whether the
defendants are guilty or not guilty it's
our duty to take these mistakes by the
authorities that resulted from poor
communication and turn them into lessons
it's not the courts job to launch
investigations into that or to compile
evidence in the end that's Parliament's
jobs off Kaabah and experimenters Zintan
as a member of this investigation
Commission you've seen how state and
federal intelligence agencies failed in
this case is it fair to say that they
failed completely it's my impression
that we're looking at a cataclysmic
failure of Germany's entire security
structures the worst since the founding
of the Federal Republic that goes not
just for the intelligence services but
unfortunately for police departments as
well our report doesn't come out till
summer mine but my preliminary finding
basically is that three factors came
together here the first is a lack of
communication between the different
authorities pieces of intelligence where
they were available were treated as
private property that shouldn't be
shared with other authorities that's not
the only thing that went wrong
the authorities massively and recklessly
underestimated the increasingly violent
nature of the neo-nazi scene also and I
see this as the most serious aspect the
investigations into the murders were not
conducted in the unbiased objective and
professional manner that our citizens
should expect we've observed that the
investigations were conducted largely in
a prejudiced manner
investigators had blinders on from the
beginning simply because nine of the ten
murder victims were immigrants they went
into the investigations with the
hypothesis that the murderers were mafia
or drug related and that it was about
protection money one of mine organized a
crime in any case they only considered
the possibility that the murders were
carried out by neo-nazis and very late
and very superficially in al-qaeda and
was a tough litigants although the first
fought Sue's ardency investigators were
prejudiced does that mean they turned a
blind eye to neo-nazis ya missin fish
tendecy well it's clear that they were
not sharp-sighted enough when it came to
the neo-nazi scenes I don't want to make
sweeping statements but look in 2003
that's three years after the murders
began investigators were still coming up
empty operating on the assumption that
the killers were people close to the
victims but instead of asking whether
that might not be the case three years
later they were saying the victims
families had lied to them
some said and I quote that it was the
Turkish mentality not to tell the truth
in light of that it's clear to me that
we have people working in some parts of
our security agencies even in some
important positions whose work is
tainted by resentment and that must not
be in a functioning democracy citizens
have to be able to count on two things
for one that the state will do all it
can to protect them from crime in this
case the state did not do all it could
to stop this series of murders by means
of better investigations the second
promise by the state is that when there
is a crime
that it be investigated objectively and
in a sustained manner active that
promise was also broken when it came to
the victims of the NSU that's why our
work and this parliamentary
investigation is so important via and
Palamon dozens also liasons VT a
frittata seep in the are you still
shocked by the fact that no one seemed
to guess for ten years that the murders
were linked not just the authorities
even the media didn't speculate about it
in does so it was that this could take
place and no one seemed to have a clue
that it was the work of neo-nazis
hundreds if the whole Western overseas
de Nieva and love them eventually the
idea did come to the investigators
although relatively late they didn't
really pursue the neo-nazi theory until
2006
and unfortunately the investigating
authorities agreed not to discuss the
idea publicly they even agreed to deny
questions by the press that there was
this idea so I can't blame members of
the press who did ask the police if the
crimes could have been hate motivated
and then got the answer that that had
been excluded as a possibility in design
I can't blame the press but the
authorities acted totally irresponsibly
the investigations weren't conducted
centrally but in five different states
by five different state attorney's
offices and six police departments and
federal public prosecutors weren't
informed that the crimes could have been
politically motivated
federal prosecutors didn't even contact
the investigating authorities directly
they concluded from reading newspaper
articles that the crimes didn't fall
into their jurisdiction so we're looking
at multiple failures multi-dimensional
failures at different levels and in
different institutions even an undecided
just three perpetrators in the end who
responsible for the murders of all 10
people or the once invention before
t-mobile and escovitch the other chaper
is not the only person who will face
trial at the court in munich there are
four other defendants who are accused of
aiding the trio by supplying them
documents and weapon
often sweetie for in the course of our
parliamentary investigation in Berlin we
haven't received any indication that
people outside this trio had concrete
knowledge of the crimes but I do think
it's possible that there are other
people who helped the three main
suspects who we don't know about yet
Federal Police themselves have informed
us that their investigations into that
possibility will continue at least into
next year that more eyewitnesses are
being questioned that police are working
to shed more light on the trio's
associations it's pretty clear to me
that it would be hard to commit crimes
like these in a country like Germany for
13 years without logistical support from
other people
I don't think we're talking about a
group of accomplices in the hundreds if
that were the case the truth probably
would have come to light earlier but
there could have at least been more
accomplices than we're currently aware
of are the unbending witnesses who as
I'm current assets are give over second
Cumbre it's mind-boggling that Germany
has this neo-nazi underground tools how
big is it how strong do you think it is
now mostly here if I lesson oft it's R
and F I can only give you the figures we
have from our intelligence agents I hope
they're reliable there are some 20,000
openly organized right-wing extremists
in Germany a few thousand of those are
part of the violent neo-nazi scene we've
known for years that a certain minority
among these extremists have discussed
engaging in militant activity in
deliberate crimes including violent
attacks and inflicting grievous bodily
harm on others that has to be taken very
very seriously our work in the
Commission is aimed not just at
correcting failures in the system but
also at making sure for the future that
our security authorities are more
sensitive and more attuned to what's
going on so the early warning systems
are effective because looking back at
the past at the crimes committed by the
NSU it's clear that authorities did not
take the right-wing extremists scene
seriously enough or even that they gave
extremists too much freedoms of you
should be home it would make sense to
adopt a zero-tolerance strategy here but
it also needs to be ensured that the
authorities are well informed and can
intervene early our intelligence
authorities already do that when it
comes to observing Islamist extremist
networks especially following the
September 11th attacks in 2001 the
authorities took on lots of experts who
have their ears to the ground and can
tell when certain Islamist circles are
becoming more militant before they
commit a crime we need that kind of
expertise and broad analysis when it
comes to writing extremism that's
something we're still lacking it's not
enough just to have the different
authorities sharing their intelligence
they also have to find better ways to
gather information all from the Muslim
offer vessel vegans of matzah ones given
often mister dotty thanks for talking to
us my pleasure